I want to do the same problem that I did
in the last video but I want to show you
that there's multiple ways to solve
these problems that should hopefully
give you the right answer if you do them
in the right way so once again one pipe
can fill a pool one and a half times
faster than a second pipe if both pipes
are open the pool can be filled in six
hours
if only the slower pipe is open how long
would it take to fill the pool so as I
said in the last video whenever you do
these problems it's very important to
think in terms of rate the rate at which
the slower pipe can fill a pool and the
rate at which the faster pipe gets fill
a pool now right over here I'm gonna
define that the slower pipe the slower
pipe can fill a pool and are so its rate
is our pools per hour our pools per hour
so if its rate is our pools per hour and
our four rate what is the faster pools
rate the faster pools rate is going to
be 11.5 times our it's one one and a
half times faster it has one and a half
times the rate so it's going to be able
to do 1.5 our pools pools per hour and
what's their combined rate well you can
add the rates are plus 1.5 R so let me
write this in orange so if you say their
combined rate their combined rate is R
plus 1.5 what am i doing plus 1.5 are
1.5 are pools per hour pools per hour
which is equal to 2.5 pools per hour 2.5
are pools per hour pools per hour and
they're also telling us that they're
telling us that their combined rate if
both pipes are open the pool can be
filled in 6 hours so they're telling us
that the combined rate is one pool in
every 6 hours so they're saying that the
combined rate is also so this is also
equal to one pool and every six hours or
1/6 of a pool per hour one pool and
every six hours one pool in every six
hours is the same thing so that's this
line right over here one pool in every
six hours the same thing as 1/6 of a
pool per
our 1/6 pools per hour and then once
again we have 2.5 R is equal to 1/6 we
can multiply both sides so we let me do
it this way we can multiply both sides
by 6 let me just rewrite it so I have
some real estate 2.5 are the units are
the same on both sides so really this
needs to be equal to this so 2.5 are
needs to be equal to 1/6 you can
multiply both sides by 6 this just
becomes 1 this right over here 6 times 2
point 5 is 15 so you get 15 R is equal
to 1 or R is equal to 115 --then let's
see how that might make sense so we know
that the slower pool is what is our
pools per hour or we could say it is 115
of a pool 115 of 8 or 115 of a pool per
hour or you could view it as it takes
one to do one pool it takes 15 hours so
once again to answer our question if
only the slower pipe is open how long
would it take 15 15 hours so once again
the exact same problem we did in the
last video just a different way and
frankly a little bit simpler although I
went is a little bit more detailed in
the last video so I don't know if if I
can make that comparison